pas
[Musique]
ils étaient treize un gramoune ce
dimanche 29 octobre à s'être rendus à
saint pierre à l'occasion de la journée
départementale des personnes âgées en
rendez vous annuel qui met à l'honneur
les seniors celles qui sont allés parler
pour lui
167 du sénonais par le département de
sakassou
les poussées offensives
au champion
pianos anciens parce que nous
même de venir
de maillage de rosnay romancière et
c'est vrai que ils ont absolument besoin
j'ai envie d'y être fermé les yeux
demeure dans les bonnes conditions les
deux rames du métro c'est grammont en
valeur même si ça n'est pas suffisant on
le fait toujours après la semaine bleue
dans la semaine le site aux personnes
âgées en ehpad et les personnes ensuite
qu'ils peuvent se replacer viennent à
cette amère
et je pense que c'est un franc succès
aux jo la journée a débuté par une messe
puis les seniors ont pu profiter de
divers ateliers tels que des stands
d'information sur les dispositifs d aide
aux personnes âgées mais aussi des
ateliers de bien-être nous présentons
donc les activités de loria pas et
spécialement sur cette journée nous
apportons un peu de plus de bien-être
aux personnes âgées sous la forme de cet
écrit là de la tête aux pieds pour les
jolies donc
de la réflexologie et du massage facial
de
l'esthétique l'associatif hic du
maquillage et des de l'onglerie on va
dire ça la manucure très bonne
initiative et c'est à renouveler c'est à
renouveler on se fait sauter la tête aux
pieds
voilà et c'est très agréable j'ai très
bien l'ambiance était au rendez vous une
journée festive et conviviale qui a
permis aux gramounes et de surcoûts dans
madame est tous les vieux les réunit
elle est là pour boire et manger le
manège le club des trois diamants
il m'a raconté un ami là ça fait au
moins 24 heures
c'est pour les personnages et nous les
personnes âgées qui sont là et il faut
passer une bonne journée décentralisée à
saint pierre pour la première fois cette
édition 2010 est de la journée
départementale de personnes âgées a été
une réussite
[Musique]